hmm
david manning no
i'm a christian
[Music]
all right welcome everybody i was gonna
play some uh intro videos and stuff but
some something's weird something weird
is going on with audio today
oh i'm muted oh my god nobody can hear
me
oh no oh god
no i'm kidding i know i'm not muted
right now there was some it seems like a
problem with some kind of technical
element before i apologize
we're gonna get everything all set up
for everybody really soon
okay so i i just i don't know what's
going on we are
54 minutes from the scheduled
appearance of former president donald
trump
he's speaking in phoenix arizona
because that's where they are
doing an audit i guess of the last
election that was like
almost a year ago now um so basically
since it's scheduled for 54 minutes from
now it'll probably start somewhere
between three and four hours from now
okay
so um in any case we're here for it i
have
so many things to talk about that i'm
glad that we have uh we have some time
actually
um and uh so just it's crazy the amount
of stuff that's been going on
and we're gonna get to that very very
soon you might notice that we have a
different coupon code than normal today
today the coupon code is my hipaa
and the reason it's up there is i think
if i didn't spell it for people
a lot of people wouldn't know how it's
spelled um
and i will give you the genesis of that
in a little bit okay so a lot of really
exciting things going on i do want to
say thanks to the font peg as well as
astro lycos
tinyaim all of whom just dropped in
some twitch memberships very much
appreciate that the counter at least is
working
that at least is working um okay
where to even start today my friends
because there are so many things oh yeah
frisky seal in fact
signing up on twitch and saying david
your coupon code is a violation of my
hipaa rights
and correctly misspelling you see how i
did that
correctly misspelling it people all over
the internet spelling it like
hippo as in a hippopotamus zach foster
also sending a super chat
says try and get vincent rasaniello on
for covid discussion
case is coming down in the uk maybe past
peak
yeah it does seem as though the delta
variant is
starting to peak and then come down uh
in europe
and hopefully that will happen here in
the united states as well
uh in fact i have video here oh no not
video i have charts and graphs look at
this spike
in the united states just massive dumps
of cases now
it's really important to understand a
couple of different things i think it's
important not to be alarmist
nor glibly unconcerned
by the case numbers on the one hand the
cases are overwhelmingly unvaccinated
people but what you have to remember is
asymptomatic cases in vaccinated people
means the vaccine worked and we turned
it into a cold like
in other words we have seasonal colds
all the time
every once in a while someone who gets a
cold
dies because they end up getting
pneumonia it doesn't even make news
in a normal situation because it's not a
novel cold it's one of the four types of
colds
and we sort of accept that there's a
certain amount of death that's going to
happen small percentage
from people getting colds if
the vaccinated are almost never getting
hospitalized and almost never dying the
fact that it's not zero
it's still sad any loss of life is
tragic but we have to be comparing it to
normal seasonality of colds never mind
flu
um over time that's what it may become
with such effective vaccines so it is
mostly
hitting unvaccinated people when we talk
about breakthrough cases
they don't really matter if those people
are overwhelmingly not getting sick
but at the same time we still have some
spread happening
uh people that are vaccinated and that
didn't develop immunity or that are
immunocompromised etc so the point is
the case spike started when did it start
i guess right around here about a full
month a month ago
we're not seeing a death spike for the
time being
and listen you know we're just going to
continue following the data
and let's quickly look at uk
um and yeah the uk decline
started to happen i guess we would say
the spike was about july 17.
yeah it's been about a week yeah so
perfect perfect uh super chat actually
pointing that out
um whoa whole bunch of other super chats
coming in
what's the context of trump saying sir
your wife is up in the air
i think it was something about he said
when what he meant by
your wife is up in the air is that
melania was like in a helicopter or a
plane
i don't even really know the context
david still need uh help locating my
wife any idea where she is yeah up in
the air as far as i know
screw delta i prefer jetblue what would
a future look like under trump well it
would look very ugly we're not even
gonna get into that right now because
it's such
it's such a negative topic all right
let's go next
this just happened uh apparently in the
last 24 hours
um tucker carlson was at dan bailey's
fly shop in livingston montana
he was confronted by a guy who told him
he's just the worst person in the world
this was a little confrontation
fox host tucker carlson here
i don't care
the worst human being known to mankind
tucker needed to get back to looking at
some you know
baits or something um dan bailey's fly
shop made clear that the individual
doing the confrontation
um is not associated with the business
but is the guy's name dan bailey that's
we oh this is really bizarre
the guy's name is dan bailey and this
confrontation happened in dan bailey's
fly shop but the guy
it's just a coincidence that the guy has
that name apparently it's mere
coincidence the guy has nothing to do
with dan bailey's fly shop what are the
odds of that
is dan bailey sort of like uh you know
joe smith in montana or something like
that that's bizarre
that's absolutely bizarre um okay
so tucker carlson confronted as we
continue to stand by for donald trump
let's listen to just a minute
of charlie kirk speaking faithful
and god-loving americans are gonna get a
little more volume i'm mad as hell and
i'm not gonna take it anymore
charlie focused in during this speech
about how his hippo was violated someone
violated his hippo
okay um so we did the tucker carlson
thing we've got some video from the uh
from the outside of today's event in
phoenix arizona which we will get to
also
actually do we do we want to do the
hippo stuff first just because it's
so pathetic i do want to say thanks to
drew nielsen for the twitch sub
as well as flying couch bowflex man
and polo dell uh putting us
at seven new members and subscribers
today
so here's the source of the coupon code
that you see above my head
the new one now is everybody when
they're asked
if they're vaccinated all of these
right-wing clowns
are claiming that the question
violates their hipaa now that h-i-p-a-a
hipaa only refers to
the transmission of health-related
documents by medical providers and
health insurance companies
it has nothing to do with journalists
but let's just take a look at some of
these okay this is marjorie taylor green
or marjorie green taylor as stephen
kenneth destiny bennell the second calls
here my god the audio is
tragically low let me see if i can find
a better video
let's see if this one has better audio
and we'll even crank it up a little bit
here we go two questions have you
yourself gotten vaccinated and do you
disagree with the republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
tell me tell me more marjorie um
that's of course not true here is dallas
cowboys quarterback
dak prescott saying it's hipaa
have you got the vaccines um i don't
necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clarence i think that's hipaa
that's hipaa guys that's hipaa so
um just as a reminder hipaa
is a law relating to
medical providers and health insurance
companies health
insurance companies having to protect
records of your medical
visits history medical records elements
of records as we might call them
when a journalist asks a public figure
are you vaccinated
that doesn't violate hipaa hippo
or really any barnyard animals of any
kind
are not being violated by that question
so that's where we get today's coupon
code myhippa
and because a lot of people think it has
two p's it actually is one p and two
ways
you can use the coupon code myhipa at
joinpackman.com
and you will get an ungodly discount off
of a membership it's a it's a discount
even hippos would be shocked by
okay so that's that's the those are the
oranges
of today's coupon code um
can you imagine though i mean it's it's
truly truly incredible so we'll come
back to that in a little bit
um let me get to a couple of other uh
whoa
we've got some major major super chats
coming in
i need to adjust my mic so i can see
them how has the right hijacked
the idea of patriotism it's wild that
kneeling for the anthem isn't allowed
but bastardization of our country's flag
like the thin blue line flag is
patriotic i'm right there with you felix
ferod
in uh super chat um yeah i mean listen
they started
trying to obtain a monopoly on
patriotism about 40 years ago
really under reagan it started and
there's a long ugly history to it
sniff says deaths in the uk are stagnant
well said
and paratyren our i think our favorite
swedish viewer
um yeah says
have a nice fika
i don't know what that means but sending
in a 500 swedish kroner super chat
appreciate that pair
philip says i watch enough of your
videos i i should todd in a couple of
bucks appreciate it we welcome todd's
and everybody else
and pear following up with hippo hippo
yes
exactly very well said very well said
uh okay do we want to do
voicemails next or do you want to do
um video from outside the prompt rally
from today what do people prefer
we'll do both i mean we're doing
everything but uh do you want to do
voicemails
or video from the rally
seems people want to see phoenix first
yeah that's fine that's fine so this is
just a couple of minutes
i don't even know if i think this is a
video from a pro maga
uh let's just see these are the sights
and sounds in phoenix
freedom isn't free trump won
[Music]
don't you guys regret not being there
was that dog the bounty hunter right
there did you guys do that
right there see him
thanks for your service brother
it's now considered sort of like cool
to say the guy who lost by millions of
votes won it's cons
it's not even like you know you see this
you see this shirt go by trump won right
here
it's not even like at this event that
wouldn't even raise questions as to
where
why do you think that like it just
it's just a given that that's okay um oh
thanks to pizza man drc
as well as g babysin for the um
twitch prime subscriptions number eight
and nine let's see a little more of this
there she is morning morning morning
what's up guys super strong port-a-potty
uh presents sorry i've been what are we
what are you doing
man i would not be caught dead here just
got
mobbed by nico mandelo nika mandello
look what is that nika mandello
not even returning anything weird
bizarre
this is so much fun guys i so wish like
if you guys don't go to events
please actually get out and do it
it's ridiculous come on your country
needs you and this is a blast
these are memories that'll last a
lifetime
[Laughter]
oh this is gigacringe wow um
you know we were in the first like 30 or
40 people in line
uh yesterday and you know i ran into so
many people that i've met at other
events
and you know a couple of facebook
friends that we just bumped into
randomly
and i mean as you see the the lines
wrapped around the block there's
probably
i guess 2 2500 people here right now
and guys this is just an amazing time i
really wish you guys could all be here
say hi
all right anyway that that's probably
enough uh i think we've probably um
seen enough of that this is now the sp
portion of the stream sponsored by mike
pillow
a few other super chats that i wanted to
mention david sur
do you think these right-wingers feign
ignorance on major issues or are simply
ignorant
a combination of the two um
i don't think it's it's super clear when
football commentators report
injuries is that also hipaa yes exactly
uh actually it's actually rhino
rhinoceros
when uh during sporting events they say
oh sir you know
um whoever broke an ankle that violates
rhino
adam says sir huge fan of your videos
from the uk thank you sir
infamous truth teller says what's
happening right now is like when you
tell your parents or someone tells you
if someone else jumps off a bridge are
you going to do it too
huh david your conversation with michael
cohen was interesting and highly
entertaining will you have him on your
show if he swears that much he's welcome
any time
absolutely anytime david sir is this
ymca playing in the background or new
mega version
that was it was maga yeah that's the new
version of it
snickerdoodle i'm surprised they're
using ymca as their song
very happy fast knocked day in a z
oh boy david sir not to keep beating
this dead hippo but for clarity if a
journalist obtained vaccine
records of mtg without patient
authorization
then hipaa would be applicable i don't
know that it would be applicable to the
journalists
i think if a journalist obtained records
of marjorie taylor green's varxination
it would be a question of whether
whoever gave her the records violated
hipaa or hippo um the jury i mean i
don't i don't know that the journalists
would actually be liable in any way
in that situation in sacramento there's
a freedom rally going on where they're
spewing nonsense about eugenics and
population control from the vaccine
not surprising my physician asked me if
i'd been taking my medicine i told him
to get off my hippo
look at claremore oklahoma and joplin
missouri
covid stats i looked earlier it's it's
very depressing
very depressing all right everybody
we're down to 37 minutes
remaining before trump is scheduled to
speak um i think i need to adjust
a little bit here i'm almost like my
posture is almost too good
where i'm kind of popping out of the
frame let's just see if we can
there we go that's a little better it
might be time to turn on my light as
well
as the sun is starting to set yeah
i think that's working a little bit for
us all right very good let's continue i
want to say thanks to corindor as well
as crimson elric for signing up and
supporting the stream via twitch
uh 10 and 11. also today only we have a
coupon code my hipaa
uh people now claiming their hipaa
rights are being violated you can use it
for an ungodly discount and i want to
say thank you to elgin
reese elgin reese just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
myhippa
and his new member number 12. if we get
to 100 i'll even open phone lines before
trump speaks just to hear from people a
little bit
um and the listen guys at this point
everybody should know
the best way to support the streams is
by signing up
at joinpakman.com and today because it
is such a special day
you can use the coupon code myhipa um
i want to oh this is super interesting
actually let me see if i can pull this
up
so i did this video last week during a
stream
it's on the second channel the second
channel of course is pacman live it's an
incredible channel
uh youtube.com pacmanlive vosh
steals giga cringe from me there's this
guy some people
know him as ian vaush others know him as
chris vosh
i'll just play the clip for you just so
you just to remind you of what the
segment was
next thing up on the agenda uh
man i don't even know how to bring this
up but
i i am going to have to uh
fire a shot across the bow at the
streamer known as vaush
or vaash and i i'm kind of going
back and forth about whether i should
even do this
right but vaush stole something from me
okay uh if i am known for anything among
the
zoomer community it's that
i came up with the term giga cringe
right
okay just check the receipts my friends
all right
look at what vaush tweeted to pim
pim tim poole today okay
not giving me any credit tim poole was
tweeting
anti-vaxx apologia and
vouch tweeted this is giga cringe dude
vaush has appropriated mine
guys we are maybe gonna have to go to
war with vaash
over this he just he didn't even like
there should be
an asterisk there or as some people call
it an
ass trick i've never understood
pronouncing it that way
there should really be a little
something there because that
i don't know or you know what that's
plagiar schism
anyway um vaush actually showed up in
the comments
and he is coming back at us really
really hard he said see you in court
so we are uh i'm probably gonna retain
celebrity attorney mark garagos to
represent me
i mean this isn't even his area of
expertise but i just think i'm gonna i'm
gonna let's see what people said
it's over for you vegous
vaush if you want to win this case
you'll need an attorney familiar with
alden's theory of cringe
i think pacman calling you vaush might
qualify his grounds for a defamation
suit
okay anyway so actually yeah i might
hire i might hire michael cohen
to uh represent me yep okay so anyway
that's the situation with vaush
hold on let's close this tab as we get
past that um
so that's pretty serious business pretty
serious business thanks to don juanatron
jen here as well as the funky baba
ghanoush i love babaganoush
for the twitch prime subscriptions also
want to say an extra special
thank you to lucas stoyanov for signing
up on my website with the coupon code
myhipa also want to say thanks to ron
felthoven for signing up with the coupon
code my hipaa for everybody telling me
that it's not working
please remember ninety percent of people
are misspelling hipaa with two p's this
is the correct
spelling h-i-p-a-a h-i-p-a-a
my hipaa and the reason that's the
coupon code today
is because of this two questions have
you yourself gotten vaccinated and do
you disagree with the republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
exactly that's her hipaa guys and here's
another one
have you gotten the vaccines um i don't
necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clarence i think that's hipaa
yep um but i understand where zeke comes
from
um i understand everybody's opinion
right every
every opinion is understood so because
my hipaa is now becoming the new thing
um we have the coupon code my hipaa and
by the way it really shouldn't
surprise us quite frankly that the
people who think when twitter bans
someone
that's violating their first amendment
rights those are the same people who
think a journalist saying are you
vaccinated to a public figure is
violating their hipaa
it's the same people it shouldn't really
surprise us right i mean it's
at the end of the day it's the exact
same thing who is this guy by the way
so what we got to do about it is we got
to make sure this audit goes through is
this paul gozar
i i see people making fun this guy may
have parkinson's for all we know i'm not
going to make fun of what he's doing
i see what he's doing guys but it's just
not i mean
it could be a medical condition and if
you go back and if you go
back to that movie i asked you to watch
kill chain you're going to find that one
of the out kill chain what
call me a liar this is the democrats in
their own word
didn't this guy have coffee multiple
times with some white supremacist
right wing guy like a charlie kirk type
not kirk but
who's the guy that this guy was having
coffee with
people remember that in chat
by the way thanks to s nehal for the
1100 bit cheer with the message my hipaa
fuentes it was oh nick nicholas fuentes
yeah
yeah yeah yeah all right so there's that
um i do want to play this is um one of
our great great so many of you are
familiar with
office akimov who does a bunch of our
remixes i also want to thank small
fuzzy moss who sends me soundboard clips
all the time
but put together this is called
gigacringe
david pakman loses it over melting rudy
this was a special day wasn't it you
guys remember this day
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off
explaining to us why trump really won
the election again
inspectors every state
almost every approved this was thrown
away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out wait
he's saying there was a dead person
in the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat
coming off of his brow i mean is this a
normal amount i don't know how hot it is
in the room but this something seems
very wrong here we'll be in the lawsuit
that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a k as a state that we're
looking at very very carefully
strongly looking at it i would say we're
probably i assume
she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time you should have had
the time and that you to go look for
them this is good
that's your job like it's my job to
defend the president
and i represent the president michigan
wisconsin
is is he bleeding did you see is he
bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that what a day
does that hair die is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
but in the material oh my god it's
everywhere ten
thousand at least and we're getting he's
gotta get off the stage and there are
other aspects of this fraud
on the morning of them someone's gotta
get him a napkin they were gonna count
okay everybody asking how to use the
hipaa coupon code it's joinedpakman.com
you go to joinpakman.com you use the
coupon code on any membership there
my hipaa but on earth it's getting onto
his shirt now
again and it was any jury would accept
as they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup
so the city described that to you oh my
god it's all over his face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump won isn't it based on this
man sometimes the streams are actually
kind of funny
uh oh man i'd forgotten about that so
it's fun sometimes i'll go back and
someone will remind me of something like
this and i'll be like that was actually
pretty that was a pretty funny day
um oh man that that is wild
uh yeah that's small fuzzy moss
maybe i'll paste the link here
i'll paste it in um twitch a couple of
times
and then i'll paste it in uh youtube a
few times so people can share that small
fuzzy moss has really done a lot of good
stuff for us
let me say a big thank you to
c cevu yt and ky
dizzle as well as the home schrecker
for the twitch subs numbers 18 19 and 20
and people are taking to the my hipaa
coupon code
like um i don't know insert whatever
analogy you want
i want to say thanks to tammy jones for
signing up on my website with the code
myhipa
kathleen arnold lisa whitehead
as well as john connell karen pierce
emily hannon and everett wool
seven new members okay 20 plus seven
that's seven plus zero is seven nothing
to carry
two twenty seven very much appreciate
that
uh yeah today the coupon code is my
hipaa
um you guys want to see crazy anti-vaxx
hate mail next
or do you wanna do giga cringe urban
dictionary update because we did get it
submitted
what do people want anti-vaxx
message
okay let's do the anti-vaxx message okay
so this is on my
instagram if you follow me on instagram
you probably already saw it you would
have already been treated to such
specialties
as oh i thought i was logged in
uh oh hold on a second
let's just let's get logged in first
continue as parkman oh no
now i've got to enter a security code
uh let's see here
instagram
we're getting this going very soon
okay yeah so anyway you would have
already seen me with my miami vice
that's a perfect beer quite frankly
anyway here's the message i got the
other day
upos don't have the right to call him
out for being an anti-vaxxer
and talking to others about it then caps
was engaged
engaged do you understand that [ __ ]
are you you are not god you do not
determine what is correct information
and what is not
reply to me please and tell me by what
authority
do you have the right to tell me i am
wrong if i don't get the jab
don't pull the science crap on am we
because i can give you a good fight for
your money on that
just tell me who appointed you the
person who decides
what is right or wrong on this issue
i'll wait now michael the great michael
seckland
uh dropping in he appointed david pakman
and everyone else who is educated and
logical so that's a pretty that's a
strong message
uh yeah i need to explain why vaccines
are good without pulling any science on
them
wow okay anyway so that's on my
instagram david.pacman
um all right so we got that i want to
say thanks to the mongoose as well as
s nehal for the twitch prime
subscriptions numbers 28 and 29.
the myhipa memberships continue to pound
in
donald bell as well as patricia lowe
sarah graves just signed up so did
cynthia schwartz
schwartz okay i thought that was a v
uh it's kind of actually the same thing
i think in german isn't the w a v anyway
also snehal patel i was mispronouncing
it
geez i apologize snehal i thought it was
s nahal
uh man we are starting to get into some
pronunciation problems here
um for which i really do apologize okay
all right good let's get a giga cringe
update i asked people in the audience to
claim
giga cringe on urban dictionary and to
credit me for it
there's a number of different um there's
a number of different things here the
top definition for
giga cringe submitted by gut digger
saying or doing something that is a
billion times more cringe than most
things
term coined by david pakman of the david
pakman show
trump suggesting bleach injections as a
possible cure for kovid
is gigacringe uh
what is this right here
the hell david pakman is an
atheist argent jewish argentine
geez marjorie green comparing mask
wearing to the nazi persecution of
jewish people is gigacringe
that's a good this is a good definition
now
what's going on with the definition my
death what is this
david pakman definition david pakman
once again insulted
the homophobes of america by being for
gay rights
later he insulted fundamentalists by
claiming the earth is more than six
thousand years old
david has a funny accent and
mispronounces double l's
claiming it's normal in argentina it is
actually
even though he does it in new york which
is nowhere near argentina that's true
um man that's that's been in
that's been an urban dictionary since
2014. that's weird
this is all kind of weird anyway let's
get away from
it it's starting to weird me out a
little bit uh okay
also what wanted to go over with
everybody
um there's a kind of funny to i don't
usually
like do much about these parody accounts
in terms of promoting them
but this one's actually pretty funny
there's a twitch account
called they only have eight followers
there's a twitch account called not
david pakman david pakman ooc
ook i don't even know what that means
um
[Music]
interesting they actually it looks like
it's just weird zooms of me sorry this
is twitter did i say twitch it's twitter
this is twitter
oh god these are kind of weird
uh weird images
it seems this is just the whole account
man some of these images are pretty
cursed
that's pretty good though uh
these are really weird anyway apparently
this is the whole account
and they only have eight followers now
10.
i don't know if this is funny or creepy
like is this a stalker technically
weird all right we got that
let's do the rand paul thing this is a
really good one rand paul
disgusting republican senator rand paul
did a town hall
someone called in and just dropped a
huge bomb on them check this out
for that we'll go ahead to our next
question now
mrs alexis tune you are live with the
senator you can go ahead and ask your
question
hi senator i am a proud kentucky citizen
and i just wanted to tell you to get
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh man all right we'll go ahead there it
is
um that's pretty aggressive i'm not
gonna lie guys
paul gosar continuing by the way look at
look at these right side broadcasting
streams
38 000 people watching
and people just dump in super actually
there's not that many super chats right
now sometimes you just see like 100 100
100 100
it's crazy what goes on and listen to
what's happening
think about think about this folks think
about
being in arizona and today we're leading
the country
in what and rightly so what does that
mean we're not intimidated what are they
leading the country in i want to get
back
i'm not aware of any metric in which
arizona is leading buddy
if we do we get back to a country
that was dedicated and conceived by god
and the founders
and restores those freedoms
liberties that come from god
make no mistake make no mistake
we are at that crossroads right thank
you
i take that
and if there's a vision of america
coming in the future
if it's a vision of seven gosars on the
liberal side
then we've lost all what but as my mom
said that i'm our her favorite
it is our duty not our choice our duty
to hold people accountable to pursue
that dream
those individual rights and liberties
he's really making very little sense
very very little sense
okay let me get to some more uh let me
do some voicemails now i've been
promising voicemails if you are
if you're joining us for the first time
and by the way listen
i see a lot of people on youtube let me
make sure it's all working right yeah
a lot of people now on youtube are are
complaining that they had to subscribe
to the youtube channel in order to chat
yeah we turned that feature on that's a
new youtube feature we enabled that
to at least have some limitation so
people can't just do drive by trolling
um
you do have to be a subscriber in order
to be able to chat now it's just like on
twitch you got to be a follower on
twitch it's the same thing guys
exact same thing everybody relax it's
all working as planned
i know you were probably used to being
able to just troll on by on youtube but
not anymore
not anymore um who's coming back out now
oh andy biggs yeah vile absolutely vile
let me get to some super chats but first
i wanna or i'm sorry um yeah super chats
hold on
joel bustamante just signed up on my
website jonathan gaffar
just signed up and eric lavonne just
signed up
numbers 35 36 and 37. why is the coupon
code my hipaa
it's my hipaa in ridicule of this two
questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
because of that this is the new bullet
point the new talking point
have you got the vaccines um i don't
necessarily uh
think that's exactly important clarence
i think that's hipaa
exactly so in celebration of the
absurdity of that
we are using the coupon code myhipa
it saves you just crazy crazy money on
my website
crazy money on my website want to say
thank you also to jen
here as well as sinner fast n
snail gifted two subs so that's
five putting us at 42
also want to say thanks to stephanie
brink
for the patreon pledge we're counting
everything guys everything counts today
let me get to super chats then i will
get to
voicemails um
i must confess trump's ser bit never
ceases to make me laugh are you enjoying
any adult beverages this weekend i had
an allagash white last night at uh a
friend's birthday party
yeah hey by the way you you guys want to
hear something kind of weird this this
might make for a good clip actually for
the for the pacman live
channel people email me about everything
like we have if i look in my um audience
what i call my audience emails folder
i have 61 000 emails in there from
since when i started the show and
started you know we because we sew off
sadly we often need to send people's
contact history
to the fbi it's just it's an unfortunate
reality
and so we log every email we get from
people in the audience it's up to 61 000
emails
i get emails about everything david you
know it looked like you had something in
your nose during yesterday's stream
david you uh you know why don't i got
one the other day david
why didn't you take any calls from women
last week i'm i find it disgusting
no women called in last week in fact i
go out of my way to pick up
the phones for when women call to try to
balance it shows like mine the young
turks sam cedar
they skew uh they skew mail so
i always try to make sure to include as
many women callers
in the call segments you know it's like
don't be mad at me i just nobody called
that's what i got okay i got an email a
couple months ago
from a guy who said david you know i
know this may not be
something you want to talk about but
it's pretty clear to me as someone who's
in recovery
that you're you're probably drinking too
much
before your live streams and i don't
know if other people have brought this
up to you and whatever
um and i don't i just don't have time to
write back to people but i was so
bewildered by it because i drink so
little like i don't even know that i've
had more than one drink
in a week since the start of the
pandemic never mind in a day
um that i wrote back and i said i barely
drink like what can you tell me
specifically like what is it that i'm
doing during live streams that makes you
think
i'm i'm drunk um
and he didn't tell me he just said
listen it was almost like
you know how if you go to someone who
really has a drinking problem
one of the first things they do is they
deny it so it's kind of a weird thing to
be accused of that because
if you say no if the person's convinced
that you have a problem they'll say well
that's a denial
um anyway they didn't tell me they just
said listen if you're not ready
to talk about it i just want to know
that i'm aware of it and i was like
this is a this is actually legitimately
crazy they didn't seem to be trolling
they didn't seem to be trolling okay
other super
chats what i mean about jumping off the
bridge it's what happened with trump
followers
okay would you ever consider bringing on
the eggman remotely for a bonus show
that could be fun
you know what i am thinking about as
some of you know i've had dr k
on before twitch streamer psychiatrist
dr alok canogia
i what i would like to do and i reached
out to dr k
about it is i would like to have a
session
where dr k streams and i stream with
jimmy from philly jimmy from philly is
this
very very troubled trumpist from philly
who was recently arrested for this is
not an exaggeration
he was chasing a group of young black
teenagers around
completely wasted he was wasted in the
streets of philadelphia he got arrested
i would like to bring jimmy on to do
kind of like uh
how did things get this bad with dr k i
think it would be
an unbelievable segment i haven't
thought about bringing eggman on but
that's
that's an idea i hope dr k goes for it
because i think it's going to be great
um don't we combat the my hipaa nonsense
with okay what's hipaa similar to what
socialism yeah we should we should say
what's hipaa
why haven't you talked about nina
turner's primary we talk
very little about primaries um
i assume we'll talk more about primaries
starting next year
in in off years we don't really there
there's just so many requests to talk
about primaries
david are you happy argentina won the
copa america yes
very happy very very happy
david wouldn't you be happier if you
gave up silly politics and took up disc
golf
i'm interested in playing disc golf very
strong coffee fun says diana
put blue chew on your sound board hire
alan dershowitz will you ever make a
segment on how to properly debate the
right wing
yeah sure i came upon
with description of female republicans
stump it look it up okay
your giga cringe in urban dictionary
saying it's your word yeah
phil dropping in a 20 canadian super
chat
did you ever explain how coveted
vaccinations became a culture war issue
in the us
yeah we have yeah we've talked about it
a lot any hopes sanity will return to
the u.s public health debate i worry it
won't actually
what do you think about hydrogen fuel
versus electric do you think the david
pakman show should run on climate change
do you think the dp should run the dp
on climate change in 2022 what's the dp
anybody know what that is
oh the democratic party man i'm an idiot
hey listen if anybody says i'm a
democratic shill and i
always explain i have nothing to do with
the democratic party that's proof right
there
i didn't even make the connection i've
noticed the trumpians can only offer one
narrative to explain political phenomena
when they
when they asked for a second possibility
they shut down no good
very well said giga is is a prefix for
measurands
thus the relevant term would be cringe
every prefix just informs about the size
like bite gigabyte yeah we know that
it's a joke roman roman we're joking
around
it's all a joke okay i want to say
thanks to the killer pepe as well as
jaxla
and freakboy for the twitch subs also
want to say
really really big thank yous to people
who are signing up on my website with
today's one day only coupon code myhipa
the discount is so big with this coupon
code that it violates hipaa
william janke just signed up using the
code
melissa dowdy just signed up and elise
kivamay just sound signed up i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly putting us at
49
whoa um
okay let's do a few more super chats and
then we're going to get to voicemails
there are so many stupid people some
people will never change
their mind i think you meant t-h-e-i-r
we should mandate max masks or vaccines
it's been done in the past
all right nick says sir i'm worried
gosar may have hurt his neck with that
head rolling during his speech
yeah i don't want to make fun of that i
don't know if he has parkinson's or
something
david sir one book i can't recommend
enough is anti-oedipus capitalism and
schizophrenia
by deliz and guattari powerful stuff
that sounds pretty good
mr david sir thank you for bringing much
needed attention to the big massive
dumps of violations
from the standpoint of hippo wow that is
a mouthful
jake slater says david i wanted to tell
you i got my first coveted shot my only
regret is i didn't do it sooner well
said
well said daniel says did you cover the
matrix-like indisputable data dump that
proved trump won the election
yeah let's actually see let me see if i
can find that
it was weird mike pillow um he like
presented data and it looked like the
matrix
um he released some packets
like what the hell are these people even
talking about you know check this out
yeah this is big news yeah this big news
why don't you pull
i want you to put the once again that
we're announcing put those pack put
those uh the data back up there again or
let it roll again hold that yeah
again it's rolling it's rolling right
now there it is guys that's the proof
right there
huge huge dumps i mean you can't even
make out a number
and it's not clear what the numbers
would tell us
and it's not clear what they tell us is
relevant to the election
and it's not clear that if it is that it
would suggest
that anything was stolen we want
everybody to know
that that this is you know that this is
what the cyber guys are going to see
this is the real deal here everybody
yeah this is pretty big from the
standpoint of data
first time well tonight we had a show
earlier but today
what's the date today brandon today is
uh july 22nd
thursday july 22nd thursday july 12th
guys can't you see it scrolling
this is proof of what i don't know but
second
2021 the first evidence
was late mike pillow didn't know what
day it was but he's sure that he can
interpret
this data correctly right now so when i
read stuff about these naysayers
that's uh this uh kevin skoglen
uh for this for some it's uh
it's it's it's indistinguishable from
parody quite
quite frankly it's like what is that
proof of
whoa is that was is that a white
supremacy sign right there did you guys
see that
it was weird let's go back just a few
seconds i don't want to misinterpret
that
eight ten times in the last few months
and it's worse there than i ever i've
ever seen it
i gotta tell you when i went to yuma a
few weeks a couple months ago
six weeks ago now what i saw was
a group several groups of people coming
across i said
where these folks coming from the number
one at that time was brazil
then you have russia and romania and
haiti
and cuba did i go back
around the rio grande valley they're
coming from the northern traffic it's
weird to point like that who points like
that that's weird
anyway we'll go back to life
standing by for donald trump donald
trump scheduled to speak four minutes
from now if you're just joining us
um we've been reviewing a whole bunch of
different things
oh i should mute that to talk yeah um
what a weird weird day very very strange
day
i want to say thank you to danforth
johnson for signing up at
joinpackman.com with the coupon code my
hipaa
putting us at exactly 50
if you can believe it if you've been
saying to yourself
i'm thinking of signing up at
joinpakman.com but i'm just waiting for
the right day
today is a great day to do it this
coupon code myhipa
it's just crazy what it does for you
it's crazy what it does for you
all right let's finish with super chats
for now even if dems pass all policies
next year do you think it will matter
for 22 i do think so
i do think so i have a friend who's who
is
as far right wing nut as he gets he
can't help but to praise trump in every
conversation and all the lies involved
how do i deal with them
p.s this whole chat lost the game
i don't know that i would talk politics
with that person
david why are gas prices so high please
explain uh because demand
exploded as people wanted to buy gas and
drive around
what is gas cost these days as many of
you know i'm off gas um
what with the the electric vehicle is
it's got to be about what three bucks
three bucks a gallon
what's the national average
oh hold on i think we gotta ban some
people
it's about three bucks a gallon
nationally national
average gas price i know in california
it's more
it's at uh
3 15 right now okay 315.
i know it's more expensive in some
places yeah i understand that
i understand that i burned out our
pillows and i burned our pillows in
protest my girlfriend was upset because
they were serta
right yeah no if you i wouldn't burn
other pillows to protest mike pillow
as a white immigrant in canada i've seen
excess racism in front of me
due to i'm in the same culture have you
experienced this in the united states
not exactly no not exactly
okay we're caught up on super chats
let's get now to some voicemails
okay let's see what we've got
uh here we go
hey david um my name is matt i'm from
arkansas
and um i have a friend that's
vaccine hesitant and we freak
we frequently debate about um i don't
know what
his uh views on are on this and yet for
the most part we keep it friendly but um
he typically circles back around to this
uh
talking point of waiting on fda approval
and how the
vaccines fair and feature testing
and i don't know meanwhile we're liking
this pandemic and already in my state
like the numbers are increasing
as we inch closer to the fall
but anyway i was wondering if you could
please address this fda
um approval issue yeah okay so um
in a very long-winded way the fda
approval thing is
uh it we're gonna get full fda approval
for the vaccines very soon
um a couple months ago one-third of
anti-vax people
said if the vaccines were fully approved
they would go and get vaccinated
a new poll came out today where 60
of the people who have not yet been
vaccinated said under no circumstances
whatsoever will they ever get the
vaccine
so it's not looking particularly good i
think is the point
okay that's uh that's where i'm at right
now
hey david um same guy all right we're
gonna we're gonna keep going because
it's another one uh here we go
hey david um my name is matt i'm from
arkansas
oh no not this issue again
there is something really weird going on
i think this is a this is a firefox
issue
oh man let me see if i can refresh here
even though i move on to the next oh
hold on what's going on do we need to
ban
people
do we have anti-vaxx in the chat
it's just outrageous what's going on
okay let me look at unread voicemails
what on earth
hey david i had a thought while
listening to your show on july 6.
is it possible that the trump family in
their interviews where they admit to the
fringe benefits but claim it's not a
crime
is it possible that their strategy is a
jury nullification
and is it that and if that's so do you
think that they're hoping for at least
one trump supporter on the jury who
would never vote guilty
just a thought thanks yeah that's a
completely plausible uh
yeah i mean that's that seems possible
to me for sure
all right yeah voicemails are acting a
little bit funky today
but i'm doing my best to bring everybody
full coverage
let me see if i can uh
we got some eggman stuff
let me see what else we got
one thing i think i'm having a hard time
with in life is like learning
when and how to balance like taking
things too seriously
like versus not taking things seriously
and being like
one thing i think i'm having a hard time
with in life is like learning when and
how to balance like
taking things too seriously like versus
oh man this is getting crazy
one thing okay all right we gotta get
away something weird is going on
something weird is going on and i don't
fully understand it
so we're going to have to get away from
that i want to say thank you to rachel
mrevic
who just signed up on my website using
the coupon code myhipa
also thanks to dana graves who just
signed up fish pickles
just signed up and emily hannon all
signing up with the coupon code myhipa
numbers 51 52 53 and 54. also thank you
to bobby2234
for signing up uh and supporting via
twitch prime
and related mechanisms really appreciate
that
there are 61 people right now somewhere
in the process of trying to get a
membership on my website we may run out
of memberships today that would
definitely violate hipaa
and if you're just joining us why is the
coupon code my hipaa today
it's in honor of this have you got the
vaccines
um i don't necessarily uh think that's
exactly important clarence i think
that's hipaa
and then also marjorie taylor green my
hipaa it's not yours it's my hipaa
two questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa right
[Laughter]
it actually you know how sometimes if
you hear a word over and over again
it starts to sound really weird hearing
my hipaa
my hipaa my hipaa my hipaa after hearing
it so many times it's sounding really
really
strange to me really strange all right
let's look at a couple other things we
looked at that already
oh listen to this this is like just
crazy i'm sure you've probably seen this
by now if you pay attention to politics
but this is a guy who got coveted got
hospitalized
and um says he still isn't going to get
the vaccine since late february
scott rowe is one of them here i am
recovering
getting out of here finally tomorrow am
i going to get a vaccine
no um why not
because there's too many issues with
these vaccines name name a few
name a few sir father former baseball
coach
the camera being in the room is a
violation of hippo disowner and hunter
caught covet and then he developed
pneumonia before you got sick
if you would have had a chance to get
the vaccine and prevent this would you
have taken the vaccine so you'd have
gone through this i've gone through this
yes sir
what a proudly defiant moment it's like
he's acting like saying this is a badge
of honor it's just very stupid and and
also
if you imagine that you don't care about
anything other than money
if you're a fiscal conservative this is
much more expensive than
what is the vaccine 30 a dose or
something like that
look at the resources being consumed by
this guy being here
and it's basically optional like if
you're vaccinated you almost certainly
won't
end up here you could it's very very
small some percentage will just like a
few people get a cold and
they die right because it becomes
pneumonia et cetera
if you're a fiscal conservative what is
the argument for saying no
to a 30 vaccine that's free to you to
end up in the hospital
maybe paying a you know two three four
thousand dollar deductible like it's
he's acting like it's patriotic it's
really just stupid financially
and from from every standpoint don't
shove it down by the road
that's what he doesn't want it down my
trout
local state federal administration is
trying to do
is shove it down your throat what are
they shoving the science
no they're showing the fact that that's
their agenda it's
agenda the agenda is to get you
vaccinated
you know who mr scalise is i know who
stays places very well
yeah anyway um this is just like
oh man it's it's really it's really
depressing you know
it's really depressing um imagine if
this guy was i mean like this louisiana
is this in louisiana does louisiana have
medicaid expansion i mean like imagine
if after all the government was paying
for this stuff too you know
um it's just crazy it's crazy i
i don't even know what to say let's see
what's happening supposedly trump is
speaking
hours of some very inspiring speeches
very very soon i want to say thank you
to
uh matthew calamari as well as dragon
daughter for the twitch
subs and gifts numbers 56 and 57.
also i can't thank enough the people
signing up on my website
if you know that there's really no
better way to support the work we do
than to get a membership at
joinpacman.com and today you can sign up
using the code myhipa
it works you just have to spell it right
a lot of misspelling happening
i can see error logs and i hate to tell
people because it's
i would love to imagine it's not
happening but um
there's a lot of misspelled uh coupon
codes people misspelling
my hipaa that's how it's spelled okay um
i want to say thank you to
tim jenkins for signing up elizabeth
woodard
has just grabbed a new my hipaa
membership
snehal patel just grabbed another one
and barb justice also signing up with
the coupon code myhippa
putting us at 61. it's pandemonium near
the stage guys people are going crazy
for trump look check out and get up to
66 off
your entire order also go to mystore.com
let's talk actually let's talk a little
bit about coupon codes you guys have a
choice today
okay you can use the coupon code as you
can see over there
rsbn to save 66 off a mic pillow
that's one coupon code or you can use
the coupon code my hipaa to save 70
off of a membership some people in the
audience want the pillow
and to you i say go get it oh look
there's an f biden shirt
in the audience right here
thanks to sheila toronto by the way for
signing up at joinedpakman.com
appreciate sheila welcome welcome and uh
make yourself known
also thanks to neptune and crash for the
twitch prime subs
uh very much appreciate everybody
signing up via twitch prime
thank you very much and we are
potentially moments away from hearing
from donald trump let's make sure that
we have uh high definition and all that
stuff oh it's blurry anyway
look at this guy out of focus blake up
here to have a few words with her
we've heard really from dozens of
potential candidates here in the state
of
arizona and as each one walks on the
stage
you get a sort of reaction from the
crowd but
no one and i mean no one outside of
donald trump
has gotten a reaction that kerry lake
got here and i'm hoping that her crew
can join us here oh somebody reminded me
this is a pretty funny video
um you guys of course know
how uh donald trump had this two
two-handed water drinking thing this
happened with biden today and it's
actually pretty funny
or yesterday yesterday excuse me
it's funny how the crowd knows exactly
what's going on
i don't know why the crowd cheering is
just so funny
i'm looking here it is excuse me
[Applause]
man
a pretty serious memetic moment i like
that that's a good one
really nicely done it's so stupid but
it's also so funny
um yeah
let me see if i can uh how can i do this
i'm trying to get some additional
voicemails going
but there's just something weird is
happening with google voice
let me see if i could there were some
good ones that i wanted to play for you
guys
okay let's see hey david cut your show
on the uh montreal cognitive assessment
um i mean is it just me or because every
time he changes the story about what the
pointing system is
how many questions there are uh you know
how much he aced it
and then now that ronnie jackson and
jackson is just a
complete sixth sentence i mean what are
the chances he just didn't even take it
um like so many other things maybe trump
keeps maybe trump didn't take the test
that's interesting actually yeah
maybe that's why trump doesn't know
what's on the test
make stuff up it just makes me wonder
you know that did he just know the first
two questions and
he just quit because he had such a short
attention span right how could he not
how could he think that the questions
get really tough if he took the test
that's the other possibility let's see
hey david touch your show man it's that
that problem is happening again
if i refresh each time
it might work a little bit better it's
kind of annoying though
to do
let's try one other david sir
i wanted to say that your bonus show has
solved all the problems in my life
problems that no one thought possible
yep now
my question is i wanted to get into the
oranges of your
uh anti-homophobia stance uh were you
homophobic as
a teenager or a young kid you know was
it something that was
drilled into you by either your parents
or your um
or your your society your friends uh or
was they uh
were they uh welcoming and accepting it
was never about other people
it was just i never it never would occur
to me
to discriminate against someone or to
treat someone poorly because of their
identity like it just that wouldn't make
any sense
so it wasn't like my parents never
talked to me my parents never came
to me and said sir you know we respect
people
we don't treat people poorly and some
people are gay unless it was just
you know it would never occur to me for
someone to say
or to reveal a certain identity and then
for me to be like oh wow that's
that's terrible you're immoral or
whatever um
yeah so it's there was never i never got
to talk about it i guess if that's the
question
what do you think i want to say thank
you to boba fetta
as well as blakey stakey
for the twitch subs number 65 and 66.
also continued subscriptions happening
with the coupon code my hipaa
i want to say thank you to chad cramer
this guy's gone 240p look at this chad
cramer just signed up
richard parish taking advantage shaina
valentino shayna welcome
welcome welcome welcome tamara whelply
has just signed up on my website
dakota jones is a new member brandon
lund
has just signed up enrique rivas
is a new member so is adam shriner
want to say thanks to danae karaus and
melissa rasheed
and of course joseph tillbrook signing
up with the coupon code myhippa
that puts us at 77.77
um super super strong
numbers coming in today very much
appreciate that
and yes it is absolutely the case that
we have changed our youtube stream
settings
you must be a subscriber in order to
chat
we now have equity between twitch and
youtube for
a year on twitch in order to chat you
must be a follower
it's just the way it is we're not
allowing anything other than that
we have now uh basically brought
youtube into parody we might call it you
must be subscribed on youtube otherwise
we're just not gonna
allow you to send any chats and even
then it would be under protest
even then it would be under protest okay
um
so that is that is that let's listen to
the sights and sounds of a phoenix
arizona trump rally
the middle's class is running on a
treadmill right now
the middles that it does not allow for
them to get ahead
and that is due to the radical and
stringent policies
that the left has put in place cringes
so people
the time is now to act and if i can call
for an
action to any of you guys right now is
to get involved
don't be afraid of the people you might
lose in your personal life
don't be afraid of the people you might
lose on social media whoa
because we're at a point in our country
that if we don't stand
up for what we believe and what our
founding fathers laid out for us
it's over it's over there's a reason why
people in cuba are risking their lives
to come over here
and escape the radical communism and the
dictatorship that's been on that country
for years do you want that here
i think the answer is no today is a day
that you
take action i should do uh oh whoops
sorry i didn't mean to pause it
hold on let's refresh um that's how i
should pitch membership instead of just
being like
hey guys you know like i'd appreciate it
if you signed up because
we kind of like you know depend on
people doing that
and if everybody canceled the show would
probably be over so like if you like
what we do to sign up
imagine if i did what this guy's doing
which is basically making the claim that
the future of of of uh our livelihoods
and of you know humanity depends on
people getting a membership on my
website
imagine if my hipaa was connected to
something genuinely serious
um it's kind of weirding me out and also
the fact that he's doing it in 144p
is weird i don't like this radical
change i've never been political in my
entire life but all of a sudden
i don't like what i'm seeing i don't
like what i'm seeing in my schools
i don't like what i'm seeing in my
community my local law enforcement the
defunding of police
what accent is this guy what dialect is
this
just recently tarrant county where fort
worth texas is located
made it where if you have less than four
ounces of marijuana
on you it's simply a citation if you
vandalize property less than twenty
twenty five hundred dollars in value
it's simply a citation
cetacean looting and rioting is
apparently stealing pot now is a cessna
citation it's that's all it is it's just
a very you know it's a
i mean it's a nice plane but that's all
it is what is being
dramatically changed in our country and
it starts with people like you people
like charlie kirk
god bless turning point if change
depends on the people that are in this
audience
that audience i mean we are really in
trouble nine years ago
started out on college campuses high
school campuses now they have various
you know events around the country to
inspire young people
because they are getting missing
spiraled
young people the they're spiraling sign
of garbage
and that's why it's also important for
outlets like ourselves to remain
in front of the public eye as much as
possible to cover
all of this rsbnetwork.com
rsb network dot com slash donate we need
your donations as well
you probably notice on the bottom of the
screen a list of names
i've had a lot of people come up to me
and say what what what is that
scrolling on the bottom of the screen
whoa those are donors
those are donors that have reached out
and said you know what i'm tired
i'm tired of what i'm seeing in the
mainstream media i'm tired when i'm
singing in my culture
and i want to do something about it
singing in my culture i don't know what
this guy's talking about
it's really weird by the way i do want
to say thank you to the continued
supporters of this stream
and who i can't imagine would ever buy a
mic pillow edward brooks just signed up
david gevin thor just signed up
brian ressler is a new member mary robb
has just signed up number 78
79 80 and 81 what a day
what a day also thanks to teddy duh
for uh signing up via twitch prime i
appreciate that if you have amazon prime
you get a free twitch prime membership
every month you've just got to use it
how funny is it that rsbn is like
promoting that they've been suspended by
youtube while streaming on youtube it's
like guys
you're on youtube right now what does
that mean you you're suspe i mean i know
they were suspended for like a day or
something
really really weird you are fake news
exactly
exactly um man a lot of
everybody's named julie apparently who
donates to the right side broadcasting
that's pretty wild we are standing by
for donald trump he's only 20 minutes
late i think it would be a big victory
if he was
if he started less than an hour late
given how these things typically go um
but maybe this one's actually running on
time to some degree we're going to see
very soon
now this is i mean the level of devotion
for these people on rsbn look at the
super chats that are rolling in
it's genuinely nuts speaking of which
let me get to my own super chats here
um okay
i i don't want to ignore these folks
kyoko asks have you vaccinated i've
never vaccinated anyone
i am vaccinated though uh have you
vaccinated as a common greeting now in
my country total violation of hippo
it violates giraffe as well and possibly
even capybara
what's your over under on cases per day
this year you nailed the decline timing
during the last spike i flipped three
people from trump due to your work wow
thank you sean
um i think we're going to see basically
uh a peak in about two weeks
but it's not like my guess i just go by
what the medical experts say
will you consider doing a video on long
coved you know
long covet is important but i don't
really know that i have anything to say
about it
so i don't know if i'll do a video
it's oz why am i banned from calling in
on discord
i i don't know of anyone banned from
calling in
i don't know anything about that i mean
sometimes there's a hundred people
waiting so i might not be able to
it's oz why am i banned from calling in
on discord got it oz yeah no we
as far as i know you're not banned i
don't know that we can even do that
david you should go to das gamalt house
in frankfurt for
great traditional german food you can
order rinsworst
all beef i'm looking to get a nice
schnitzel for my one day in frankfurt in
a few weeks
um
you know it was really weird i i
actually sometimes i question
whether i even should be in this
business because i i'll talk about
something on stream and i don't know if
it's that people aren't really listening
to like they're listening in the
background but it's so common that
people misunderstand what i say
so i'll give you two examples two weeks
ago
i said i'm going to spain
in august um i'm going to have one day
in frankfurt
and i want to go and get since i do i'm
not going to have any of the
infamous worsts because i don't eat pork
but i would like to get a chicken
schnitzel i got three emails from people
saying david i heard you say you were
going to be in berlin for one day
i have recommendations for you the word
berlin was not mentioned once during
that stream
just not not even a single time i said
i'm going to be in frankfurt for one day
so that was weird people saying they
have recommendations for berlin
and then a bunch of people writing to me
saying
david you don't have to worry about
pork in schnitzel because it's either
chicken or veal
and veal is beef what
what i just didn't talk about anything
like that
so anyway clearly i need to work on my
by by the way i just finished reading uh
lawrence wright's going clear
science one of scientology's big things
is they teach you how to communicate
effectively
maybe i need to um maybe i need to
to take some scientology courses or
something like that i don't know
excellent book though really really
great book i suggest people check it out
i want to say thank you to dr werewolf
for the twitch prime subscription number
83 today very much appreciate it
also want to say thank you to cameron
bryant who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code myhipa
also sophie mcarthur has just signed up
brian cretch
is a new member and brett kah has signed
up at joinpackman.com
if you're just joining us donald trump
is 23 minutes late
for his rally and the reason that
today's coupon code
is my hipaa is uh because of these two
clips right here
two questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa right
okay and then here's another one have
you got the vaccines
um i don't necessarily uh think that's
exactly important clearance i think
that's hipaa yep
so as a result of that today we are
using the code
my hipaa i will tell you the discount is
70
and it probably violates hipaa
to even use it okay
let me get back to a few other super
chats natural selection like they love
to spew
would have taken care of them and our
national iq would have risen
we keep saving these q idiots with
science
that's pretty aggressive yeah i don't i
don't subscribe to that
david it'd be interesting to hear your
opinion on che guevara especially as an
argentine american revolutionary hero or
mass murderer or both
for me you know i am not in fact i just
read another book hold on a second
um
try i want to make sure i get the book
right
uh
what is the name of this book uh
conga what i really want to make sure i
get this right oh man i'm not able to
find
it's a book about a guy who ran in the
army
a um sort of like a
mercenary group almost in the congo
and they were fighting against a group
that reportedly was run
by che guevara uh
i forget the name of the book maybe
somebody can find it
anyway yeah i'm not like i i don't find
anything super interesting about chicago
i know he's from argentina so am i
um i'm not i'm not a socialist i'm not a
communist i'm not a uh
marxist and i'm not a
you know i'm not part of the
revolutionary left
so i don't know i mean i don't know what
people really i don't have any hot take
about him it's just his political views
were very different from mine
i want to say thank you to brianna
cheadle for signing up with the coupon
code myhipa
also sherry salstrum just signed up
numbers 88 and 89. what a day
an incredible day glad to see everybody
here
um let's look at a couple of other
super chats see what we've got
denver says fortunate sun is an ironic
song to be playing for trump
nettle says david what do you think
about a federal tax credit for people
who get the vaccine 100 or 500 bucks
similar to aca
i'm not against that i think a 500 it's
probably way too high
um you know it's hard to figure out what
the right amount would be 500 seems high
neighbors rally to replace a stolen flag
in lakewood youtube searched that my
story made the local news
i can't play local new local news is
extremely litigious when it comes to
copyright
so i try to avoid playing local news
clips it's very dangerous
um go fund for the rich
that guy dying for subscriptions reminds
me of a televangelist seems about right
alexander hegstad says are the names
scrolling across screen your graphics
with your members or part of the
broadcast
no no no these are all right side
broadcasting donors
uh a lot of karen's as you can see look
at that
isn't that something
it's endless cairns
yep those are those are not my donors
should the gop change their mascot to a
hippo
sure david have you looked at the
america first policy institute
looks like trump government in exile
members are former cabinet members in
similar roles
i have not my parents who are liberal
bottom my pillow before everything with
the ceo happened i can confirm they are
genuinely nice
9 out of ten people who write me about
the mic pillows
say they are not good
um i live in frankfurt schnitzel is
either pork or veal
ask for an original wiener schnitzel for
veal so so
so what is it that when it's such when
it's chicken what is it it's a different
uh
what is it called in germany
when i google chicken schnitzel i find
it i don't know
from what i'm seeing schnitzel can be
any kind of light meat coated in
breadcrumbs and fried
uh that that's what i'm fine finding
people know what i'm talking about it's
like the argentinian milanesa
come on guys everybody knows what i'm
talking about everybody knows the deal
i'm talking about
god okay i want to say thank you to uh
sharon brown for signing up with my
hipaa
eli navlin for signing up kitzman josiah
and donald stordal uh putting us
at 93 really strong numbers also thanks
to
es let's pla for signing up with twitch
prime
as well as racine knitter
number 95 today won
is number 96
very much appreciate that other super
chats david sir when is biden making
mango cheap again i'm still waiting on
this proposal to be brought to the floor
yeah okay so i'll um that's a good
reference
i'll play that clip for you uh
diamond silk mango pacman let's see if i
can find it
uh yeah it's one of our youtube
shorts
mangoes my bag of mangoes up under trump
cost me eight dollars
up under trump that's an interesting
term
up under trump i love mangoes too
nine cents okay now that we are up under
our bodies regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three bucks each
yeah that's it i want i think they're
250 each sometimes
what eight or 11 bucks that sounds good
then the american people
belie highway rivalry is what you're
doing
bring my mangoes back
[Music]
the down crowd not identifying with the
mango material
i'm looking actually for mango is there
any place
in is there any place in berlin where i
can get
mango schnitzel please send me the
recommendation guys i need that mango
schnitzel
david thank you you do good coverage
solid all the way good stuff thank you
my friend had oh hold on where did that
go my friend had a
che guevara t-shirt that he attached
googly eyes to and it cracked me up
i am block dragon from the damage report
me and a lot of our members just want to
say thank you for all that you do to
promote the truth
thank you can anybody tell me what this
is block dragon
it sounds cool
is the damage report is that john's john
on tyt's show but is that a block dragon
related to that or a different damage
report
okay nobody knows good
dragon is their mascot
well welcome everybody i appreciate that
thank you mr pakman sir what are you
most looking forward to hearing from
president vote dumps tonight much
respect from glasgow scotland
i'm curious how many times trump will
say sir that's basically it
what will the tone of your show be when
trump passes away celebratory or merose
oh i'm sure we'll be off the air by then
the show has been circling the drain for
a decade just talk to the trumpists
david what is the answer to world peace
i would say i would say what is the
question
what question is world peace the answer
to
that's how i would say it that makes
that makes a lot more sense to me
okay david sir how can i motivate myself
to read more i want to read more books
but barely have time and i have a side
hustle too
so the the my recommendation would be
just establish a number of pages you
want to read per day
and commit to just doing that and make
it reasonable right if you can only read
10 pages a day
set a reminder set something on your
calendar whatever
and you only you know you move the
reminder to the next day when you've
done it
i also suggest reading first thing in
the morning okay
whatever your routine is your alarm goes
off
instead of getting on your phone just
grab the book and read the 10 pages
it'll take you 10 minutes
then go to 15 pages or whatever that's
my recommendation
um and also have have stuff that you're
interested in reading
you know have stuff available that
you're interested in reading
i want to say thank you to jonathan
flanagan for signing up with the coupon
code
my hipaa joan gilbert has just signed up
with the coupon code
my hipaa dallas manuel
has just signed up with the code myhipa
and travis barker great to have you here
always love having drummers on stream
fellow drummers travis barker just
signing up with the coupon code
my hipaa very much appreciate that
that puts us at one hundred
one hundred one hundred very important
talisa says gefluge schnitzel
is not a traditional german thing
hard to find just suggesting great
restaurants there are many delicious
german foods
all right my hippo got the vaccine
and every metal object in the house
sticks to her
suck the nails right out of the walls
nicely done sinsu very very nicely done
that's a 1 1 out of 500 super chat
um yeah
very very well done just signed up
violating my hipaa
i think rsbn is listing the names of
every donor ever
yeah they've moved from karen to kathy
um
sir do you know of any hair loss
prevention products that actually work
so
my understanding from the standpoint of
hair loss
is that there are like two things that
actually work
um
whatever is in rogaine i think is one
thing
um i don't know a ton about it
so let's see here ah okay
so my understanding is that there's two
things that work
finasteride commonly known as propecia
which blocks the formation of dht
male androgen hormone which contributes
to hair loss that's one
and then secondly minoxidil which is
often sold as rogaine
i think basically everything else is a
scam
as far as i know there's some question
about
platelet-rich plasma which uses
platelets in your own blood to stimulate
hair growth i don't know if that's even
proven and it's very very expensive
and then there are surgical
interventions that work
um i think certainly convalescent plasma
would work
um no but in all seriousness you know
the surgical stuff where they take
um i think it's like you know i don't
even know how it works
but i apparently you need deep sedation
to do it like it's real surgery
um
[Music]
yeah yeah that's my understanding of it
some of you will remember that uh
tv director natan natan pakman
known to some as guatom started losing
his hair
quite early and explored options at that
at that point in time i want to say
thanks to joseph castaglioga
who just signed up in his new member
number 101
101 an incredible number want to say
thank you to dr
werewolf for gifting five subs on twitch
also the portland report gifting one
putting us at 107
unbelievable other super chats coming in
as we wait for donald trump
ben says why don't you eat pork i
thought you were an atheist
yeah it's not for religious reasons i
just i don't eat pork for the same
reason i don't eat whale
and i don't eat um dolphin
i don't know if that's even a thing um
i've just sort of like determined there
are certain animals whose
intelligence and sociability is such
that i'm not uh
i'm just not eating them i'm not
introducing any new meats
into my life essentially that's really
where where things are at
i did now as some of some people may
know
i did accidentally have a clam chowder
in martha's vineyard a year ago
which unbeknownst to me i later
determined had a little bit of uh
pork fat it was it was edgy
it was edgy i want to say thanks to
joseph yenner for signing up at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
myhipa
if you're just joining us the new
talking point among the republican right
is if a journalist asks you are you
vaccinated they say that's my hipaa
here's marjorie taylor green two
questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
her rights she is asserting her right to
hipaa
here is dallas cowboys qb dak prescott
have you got the vaccines um i don't
necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clearance i think that's hipaa
right that's hipaa clearance they didn't
get clearance
clearance to ask that question
leslie nielsen fans will recognize that
uh
that violation um
yeah so anyway you can use the coupon
code myhipa as a result of that
and it's just it's just such a great
coupon code joinpakman.com is the place
to do it
and it's a great thing china exactly
let's do a few other super chats as we
stand by for donald trump
uh oh i just got a notification that my
stream
just became unstable
i hope that we're not gonna have an
internet problem here because we're just
getting to the good stuff
um i'm starting to think we're not
getting trump's new health care plan
you know john i think you're right i
think you're right
david i'm going to buenos aires next
year recommendations for restaurants
attractions etc oh my goodness there is
just
so much depends how long you're going to
be there i would check the wiki travel
about buenos aires i mean it's
it's such a big city it's i couldn't
possibly
give you any recommendations just off
hand
watch doge says sir can you please
pronounce
chicken in spanish yeah i say pocha
yep i'm argentinian guys oh it's so
funny oh oh oh
yeah i mean that's how we say it in
argentina
hey david do you have an opinion on
biden saying that getting rid of the
filibuster would be chaotic despite
despite the fact that most democrats i
think want to get rid of the filibuster
i have not seen biden say that let me
review it and then i'll follow up
tony says thanks for streaming the game
overture says just got here david where
are we on a scale of pre-pillow guy to
post pillow guy
uh i don't know what that means i'm not
sure i understand that reference
the hair transplant surgeries aren't
always successful joe rogan had it and
it didn't take true story is that true
rogan had that i've never heard that
before
that's strange
david sir meow much love oh hold on i
skipped one love the show utyt and
majority report
are the only shows i watch now that's a
lot of stuff to watch
uh much love from britney and adam in
jacksonville thank you greetings in
florida currently covet hell
check out these numbers
from florida look at what's happening
here
so if we look at yesterday florida had
13 000 of the sixty seven thousand new
cases in the entire country
wow that is a big number
big big number so all sorts of trouble
happening in florida
david sir what's your stance on eating
octopus i understand they're quite
intelligent as well
yeah i'm basically off of octopus now i
am in
um i am in august going to be
in the northwestern region of spain
called galicia
and they have a very particularly good
octopus and i've decided i am going to
be
exempting myself from my own rules
uh i will probably be having some
octopus there
yeah would you raise a child in
argentina invasive question have a
two-year-old enjoy their culture more i
question the stability of the country
here's the thing about argentina and
this is the case with a lot of
countries that are less
stable than the united states if you
have a remote work job where you are
paid in dollars
and you're going to live in one of the
major cities probably in buenos aires
you can basically buy a stable
first world situation that's the sad
reality
for the people who can't do it so if
you're in that situation
i mean if i had a kid the idea of
spending half the year in argentina so
that they have the culture sounds
interesting but why
because my business income would not be
affected by that
i would continue to earn in u.s dollars
and it would basically be fine right i
mean you know you have access at a
reasonable rate to private hospitals and
all these different things
that's a very very different situation
than what
the average argentinian is living right
now
that's just the reality so um
and and then there's a case to be made
that what are you
you know to do that that you're doing
something wrong or bad
right and we could talk about that as
well but that's a tough one
that's a tough one have i seen montana
man tucker confrontation yeah we looked
at that earlier
cepheid says daniel
sir is fear of isms just one generation
of fear of the next
one generation sphere of the next i
don't know that i would simplify it like
that
but there's definitely something to that
just fear of what's coming next
i agree i want to say thank you to steve
vasera for signing up with
joinedpakman.com coupon code myhipa
also thanks to enrique rivas and
harold hogan hounds
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
putting us at 111
did you guys just see an intro an
interruption of the stream because i'm
getting a message again that the stream
has become unstable
and that is very much very very much
concerning me
no okay good was trump supposed to go on
at 6 eastern yeah he's 45 minutes late
right now
45 minutes late and i'm getting that
message from restream so it's not
specific to twitch or uh youtube
not specific to one or the other let's
listen to what's happening i do want to
see what the latest is
they look for higher guidance and all of
this a higher calling in all of this
so that is why it is important in the
biblical framework of
all of this as this country is rsbn a
biblical channel
leftist communist agenda oh my god
that our country is under attack right
now and if you as a christian
do nothing and remain silent
it's shameful look at my
african-american over here
look at him do not come from are you the
greatest you know what i'm talking about
unbelievable okay agnostic atheist
in a way i must forgive them because
they do not this is highly memetic that
they're doing
but i'm calling all christians out there
all of them
donald trump was the most pro-life
president in our history who would
believe that who would possibly believe
that
first of all there was no anti-choice
essentially no anti-choice progress made
under trump's presidency fortunately
fortunately and number two trump was
pro-choice until he was 68 decided to
run for president and claims he once met
a kid he liked
and was like oh the kid if they could
have been aborted i wouldn't have met
that kid
now i'm pro-life who possibly would
believe that
who would possibly believe that i didn't
elect donald trump to be the moral
compass of my life i didn't
like donald trump to marry my daughter
or anything like that what i elected him
to lead this nation this nation under
god
in the right direction and that's what
he does so i'm calling christians out
there to rise up
and make your voices be heard
in all of this and if you're in a church
right now if you're in one of these woke
churches why would anyone be watching
this from a church in the public scare
of of what the
the bible says how our policies should
be written
and how the bible approaches uh social
issues
if your church is not stepping into that
find
another church every time the music goes
down it comes back up
i think we're about to get that
announcement actually
this is one of the south my camera guy's
shaking his head right now
this is almost one of the lead up songs
that he likes to walk out on these
people are absolutely depraved
absolutely and completely depraved guys
i mean this this
is absolutely nuts we are we are screwed
as a country here
um
many gop think the part of the brain
called the hippocampus is where
anti-vaxxers go to college enjoyed your
cohen chat thanks ali
if you would have a kid would you love
the kid that is a reference to former
producer lewis i actually saw former
producer lewis last night might see him
tonight
uh always loved the reference being from
england i skirted around the u.s
political scene since watching your show
i'm hooked on the political train
derailment that was trump
thank you is trump always late to the
rallies yes
as a christian i'm disgusted by them
using christianity as a prop to further
their cause
yeah i'm not not as a christian but i'm
with you i'm with the sentiment
do you think anti-vaxx is fear or hate
of needles
no no no no no it's much more
much more complicated than just about
being about needles
absolutely not um
some people asking how to sign up for
twitch prime
guys at this point i don't know how else
to say it if you if you're on desktop
there's like a blue button
over the video and it's like free
subscription available
and um on mobile i'm i'm not actually
totally sure but
can you do it on mobile do people know
you can right yeah it's like right below
the video or something
yeah amazon's got to be linked to twitch
yeah
yeah okay all right looks like trump's
about to come out australian
citizen support the president here
despite what the mainstream media pushes
out as far as his narrative and she said
absolutely
they can identify with putting your
america first they can identify
with putting your country first the
people first the values of your country
so the president has a lot of support
around the world
that's why he needs our help the spread
the message
spread this message this is all very
cultish language like of uh
as the super chat says here what's the
difference between trump and jim jones
trump would charge for the drinks
it is very jim jones-like a great great
book
um let me see what was the name of this
here's a book i would highly highly
recommend
the road to jonestown jim jones and the
people's temple by jeff guin
fantastic book fantastic book
um hobo spidey marsh
paulo man of sibalba
have just signed up via twitch numbers
112 113 and 114. very much appreciate
that
also remember these are the last moments
to get your my
hipaa memberships in oh look this guy
froze
i mean the great scott pressler oh my
god
um we are we are celebrating my hipaa
have you got the vaccines um i don't
necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clearance i think that's hipaa
um but all right exactly clarence two
questions have you yourself gotten
vaccinated and do you disagree with the
republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
her rights have just been violated sir
um anyway so because of that that's the
new talking point
my hipaa is the coupon code today you
got to spell it correctly though
i want to say thank you also to cairo
kid for subscribing via twitch prime
very much appreciate that
we are apparently moments from donald
trump
david love your show great work sorry
i've been out of the loop are you in
favor of having the choice to vaccinate
i haven't
don't trust everything we are told i i
am
not for government mandatory vaccines
but i am fine with
you need a vaccine to go to a restaurant
you need a vaccine to do this you need a
vaccine to do that that's business is
making those decisions
but i uh i think trying to make vaccines
government mandatory would be political
suicide
who's wondering that trump led everybody
waiting as he always did
yes it's not going to happen step aside
donald j
trump what
is that charlie spork we lost audio now
with the perfect time huh
[Music]
all right everybody what you've all been
waiting for
the fire marshal says that we are at
capacity and we couldn't find a venue
big enough
for the man who fought for all of us
right who won
the surprise election in 2016
and did everything he said he was going
to do
the 45th president of the united states
president donald j trump
it comes from china donald trump donald
trump
china will be the 45th
president of the united states
you've touched on maybe the most
important thing this president has
brought to the table
it's a change in washington you actually
have for the first time in nearly a
decade very honored and grateful
that he was you know signed the first
step back this is really
you lean wild right or you're in the
middle you
have to be a fan of what he's done for
the border patrol
he's done more in the first hundred days
than the last two administrations have
done in 16 years
it is honor and privilege to announce
that i will nominate
judge brett kavanaugh judge neil gorsuch
amy coney
we must have american dominance
in space the usmca is estimated to add
another 1.2 percent to our gdp and
create countless
new american jobs our stock market is an
all-time unemployment is at a 17-year
low do you miss me
oh my god this is insane
please welcome the 45th president of the
united states of america
donald trump
i will build a great great wall
on our southern border and i will have
mexico pay
for that wall grab him by the pitcher
[Music]
look at my african-american over here
look at him
are you the greatest you know what i'm
talking about
okay
oh man
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
[Music]
where there's pride in every american
heart
the song's sort of going on a little too
long and now he's kind of
having to stand awkwardly this is really
[Music]
weird
[Music]
look at these people
[Music]
cause huh ain't no doubt i love this
[Music]
[Applause]
land
my god he's just still standing there
they need the timing of this is not
right i mean he's
he's just standing how strange is this
[Music]
i didn't realize it was going to be a
cringe stream
it's a giga cringe moment yeah he look
at him look at this guy
[Applause]
it has not been easy for a man you know
i started off in brooklyn
my father gave me a small loan of a
million dollars it has not been easy for
me
[Laughter]
oh dear god
well thank you very much thank you and
thank you to charlie for that
introduction which was so beautiful and
for your fearless leadership of turning
point action and turning point usa
whoa already slurring up a storm
let me also express my incredible
appreciation to the
thousands of bold young and proud
american patriots that are with us today
what a crowd what a crowd
and you think this is a lot of people
you ought to look outside it's about 110
degrees or something
it's an incredible group so thank you
thank you to the people outside we love
you
you are the pulse of our movement so
true and you are the ones who will
make america great again
i know it's out of sync that's that's
the feed guys
even people in the rsbn chat are saying
the audio is bad
good again again think of that
think think about that because nobody's
done what we
did in four years the greatest economy
we will be talking about it we have
plenty of time does everybody have some
time
yeah should be a two-hour uh speech yeah
[Applause]
i said i look forward to the speech they
said oh good i said how long a flight is
it about five and a half hours sir i
said oh well man can we maybe do it by
zoom
sir we'll never replace the real thing
do we agree
especially for our great young students
it cannot it cannot replace
being in the classroom can it with your
help we will stand up for democracy
and for justice we will fight for truth
transparency and accountability and we
will not stop
until we have restored our american
birthright
of honest free and fair
elections here we go absolutely and
completely pathetic
this guy is just here in phoenix to show
our support for
election integrity and for the brave and
unyielding conservative warriors
in the arizona states